It was a good [ __ ]
hmm dj Good
Abe Gaze Belturi Yoshikiyo
[music]
car Even if the
rabbit ran away, what
are you doing?
Okay,
good girl, people are dirty
, I don't think your show has teeth, but on market day, I'll hit the kitchen through
there
Serious and kind, you're sure to be able to become a ninja.
Mother pop
tan I
don't go out with you
3 hours in a world without lies is each profit
Yes, I
'm withering so I'm giving up already Fried and baked
depending on the horse
ni
ana
Shinobi secrets that exceed the opponent's predictions
Worst floating book
Voice entered
[Applause]
ran
ん magical expansion pressure
[music]
North
I think it's a princess